[Music]
good morning everyone and thank you for
joining me today here it's it's a
pleasure for me to be here today today
I'm going to talk about how a
traditional optimization techniques can
be combined with with location
intelligence in order to build a
powerful optimization algorithm that can
be applied for example to improve
traffic in in large cities so these two
pictures I took them in the last two
weeks on to random days and this is on
my way to work and so every day when I
go to work I use my bike to go to work
and go back home and this is what I have
I find every day as Pablo said I live in
in Madrid which is a city with a very
poor bike infrastructure so that means
that I have to share so I have to share
the infrastructure with cars and this
makes it this makes it well quite
difficult sometimes even very
inconvenient because if there's traffic
there's traffic for me too even though
well I'm sure that I'm I'm doing
something good too in order to reduce
this traffic and well a well time ago I
started taking a closer look at the
other cars around me and when I go to
work and when I go back home and I
realized that more than half of those
cars are taxis or rideshare vehicles and
among all of them more than half of them
are empty so if you go in the morning
like this is Gran Via Street in Madrid
if you go there and you take a look at
the taxes and right here vehicles you
realize that most of them are empty so
taxis are looking for some clients to
flag them and stop them and well right
share vehicles are driving is so that
they trying to find a high demand stone
so that they get assigned to to do a
trip service let's say so when I realize
about this well if you think about it
traffic is one of the main sources of
pollution
in in large cities and car
infrastructure takes a lot of the space
that in cities that we could use for
bike infrastructure for example but also
for parks or simply simply larger white
sidewalks or for people to enjoy their
cities so the idea today here is that
I'm going to introduce you to
optimization how to apply optimization
in order to to let's let's think about
an alternative and how we can think
about this service and provide it in a
different way before I start we all know
that the service that taxis and and this
ratio companies providing cities is
essential because not everyone can can
take a bike or public transportation if
we think about elderly people well they
probably cannot go and take a metro or
or a bus because they just can't
so these service is essential so here
what I thought about is what if we could
think of new legislation because we've
seen with racer vehicle companies that
well they they some time ago they said
ok we are here to reduce traffic but the
truth is for example at least in Madrid
that traffic is even worse so I think a
new legislation is needed here what if
we had a new legislation in which for
example we couldn't flag taxis on the
street so they had to wait in in certain
locations throughout the city or you
could order some taxi service through an
app like like you do for for others but
just for for everyone so for taxis and
also ricer ricer companies so based on
that the thing is since this is a very
essential service that the cities need
we need to have a fast response so when
I need a taxi so today I'm used to
having a taxi when I need it so I just
go to down the street and I flag it's
actually I get a taxi it's very fast so
how can we make this fast but without
having taxes and without being able to
flag them well we're on the street ok so
this is my focus today is is going to be
on on how we can apply
optimization in order to reduce this
times this waiting times let's say they
well at the same time reducing the the
amount of traffic that we have in the
cities so this is the problem that I
want to solve and if we think about this
problem these are the components if we
think about the components from a
mathematical point of view that we have
to solve this problems so we have the
the drivers current position so they are
located in certain places they can be
like driver a they can be serving an
order so they can be travelling so
taking one person from one place to
another or they can be idle like driver
be at a different location and then we
have the pickup points and the drop-off
points so the places where we have to
pick up customers and the places where
we have to drop them okay so if we think
about this we have different locations
we have to take we have to drive from
one place to another and as our goal
here is to minimize the empty D and the
empty drive driving hours or empty
driving distance in this case so what I
have there are different nodes in my
city and I have different connections
from one place to another and I have the
distances from one place to another so
basically I have a network here and the
problem to solve is to minimize the
empty distances we could also minimize
the the DMT driving time in this case I
focused on on distances and so what we
have is a typical routing problem okay
which in optimization in mathematics
have been widely studied throughout the
years so we have a lot of you have a lot
of algorithms to to solve them and there
are even a lot of software there are
commercial software and free solar
software to solve this type of problems
the only thing is what we find here
which is that I so when I thought about
this problem you actually have to make a
difference between what I call the
traditional versus on-demand in this
case last my transportation but in
general traditional versus on-demand
transportation problems and let me stop
here a little bit to make to explain
what's the difference so basically
traditional optimization or routing
problems are the for example the problem
that Amazon faces every day
so you can you can make an order to
Amazon and normally they tell you well
you get this delivered in three days if
you're a premium next day but it's
always at least next day so they have
plenty of time or well they have at
least some hours before they they plan
all the routes that they have in order
to deliver all those orders and they
have all the information so they know
all the writers or yeah they know all
the drivers that they have they know the
fleet of vehicles that they have
available so traditional logistics
problems basically you have all the
information you need in order to find
the optimal solution so they said the
characteristics of these programs are
you have all the information beforehand
and normally solution is not a need it
is not needed immediately so what I've
worked in in my previous company in in
projects related to logistics and there
are some clients that think that 1/2 an
hour in order to get a solution is good
enough because the the alternative to
that is one person building those those
routes and that that takes longer so so
yeah so you don't need an immediate
solution because it's for tomorrow if we
had to classify these sort of problems
again its routing problem here within
optimisation these type of problems are
a vehicle routing problem which is a
problem that is characterized by what we
just said so we have different D ports
or places where we have our fleet and
different points that we have to visit
and we have to minimize distance in this
case ok and in in the in the case of
traditional routing problems the main
challenge is actually being able to
process so take into account all the
other information we have so all the all
the orders that we have to deliver so
all the places we have to visit and and
being able to actually find a solution
that if it's not optimal but this is
nearly optimal okay so that's that's the
main a challenge there but now this so
the only problem is that our problem
which is an on demand because you get an
order and you have to service at them
immediately
it's it's not solvable
bye-bye most of the software that is
being developed for for traditional ones
and why is that because well our problem
on the on-demand transportation problem
it's an easier one from the point of
view of the information you have
available because you only have vision
of a time window so you can be I don't
know some seconds or some minutes but
you don't know so you know what happened
before but you cannot change it so you
really don't care about what happened
before and you don't know what's going
to happen in the future you can forecast
it but you don't know it okay so and
this is the problem that is called in
literature is called a narrow narrow
vision problem which is the fact that
you even though you have to solve a
problem for a whole day you only have a
vision of a very very short period of
time and if you make that decisions you
could this could lead to two very
inefficient planning okay so the
characteristics again are the narrow
vision the orders has to be processed
right as how in almost real-time and and
well when we classify this problem it's
it could be classified as a vehicle
routing problem but it really depends on
the information we are going to take
into account again since we have only a
vision of a very narrow window we could
go from a vehicle routing problem but we
could also see it as an assignment
problem that we'll see today because
actually in a narrow window you only
have like some some new orders that you
receive some drivers that are available
and you just have to match them okay and
that's an assignment problem so here it
may seem like an easier problem but
actually it's it's a little harder to
solve it has two main challenges one
which is to how to overcome this narrow
vision so here the main goal is okay how
can I add more information to my problem
to make better decisions and then a more
flexible solutions yeah decisions sorry
so that if I make this decision so if I
make one assignment maybe I can I can
reassign it later that's that's one of
the main challenges and the other one is
that you need an instant solution so you
can in order and it cannot take you half
hour to tell you okay so this is the
taxi you're going to get because
otherwise you
you just don't wait okay so today we're
gonna be focusing on the on-demand
transportation problems this is just the
map this map is showing well I simulated
the the services the service orders that
we get from 7 to 12 p.m. on a Thursday
based on some some data that I used and
well here what you can see is what I
wanted to show you is this narrow vision
problem that we have so here once a
service is no longer there it's that you
cannot do anything to change it so
that's that's one of the problems that
we have here ok ok so now we introduce
you to the problem that you face every
day on my bike then I translate it I
translated it into into a mathematical
problem with the characteristics now
these are just now I'm going to solve
this problem but I made some assumptions
to make it easier for this presentation
and for for for everyone to understand
and these assumptions are like my focus
is going to be to minimize the total
empty driving distance okay you could
take also time but I decided distance
for two reasons because well it's it's
easier to see when you draw it in a map
how-how's solutions are different and
and also because well if you drive less
distance well it's it's less time that
you are on a road occupying space while
you're empty then every tip is
independent well the two next points
basically mean that a driver cannot be
assigned to another trip order until a
his idle and then the type of lead is
the same for every driver just again to
make things simpler and we will always
have enough I don't drivers to assign
two trips ok this is not in real time
this is not what happens in real life
because we have we can have peaks of
demand where you don't have enough
drivers for all your orders but again
here for today we're going to focus on
on this ok and this is another yeah and
this is the
the timestamp in which I'm going to
focus again in order to - in order for
for make results easier to understand
okay so this is using Carter builder and
here what we have are the the services
that we have from 7:00 to 7:05 p.m. and
you can see the initial positions of of
course they can be idle or not and then
we have in in green we have the pickup
points and in in pink we have the
drop-off points okay so basically and
well in yellow are the the minimum
distance from pickup - to drop-off
points and well the idea here is okay
let's see how we assign these cars - to
these services so that we minimize the
MT driving distance okay and I'm going
to do this following different steps
okay and I'm going to be adding more
complexity to this so the first thing
that you could think okay I have this
problem in which I need to to provide a
solution in real time so the first thing
you could think is okay if I think that
I need to provide a solution in real
time and customers experience is
important so I want I want them to have
a car as soon as possible you could
think okay so every time I get an order
hi services so I find the the driver
which is closest to to that to that
pickup point and I assign them okay so
you could think with this is a good
algorithm and this is what we applied
here so basically there you can see the
the first six iterations of the
algorithm and basically this algorithm
activates every time I get an order so I
get an order I assigned the the closest
a driver who is idle in this case we got
a solution with a total distance of
empty driving of one hundred and eighty
one point seven sixty seven kilometers
okay and so this is going to be like our
baseline model in order to compare how
we improve with next steps and so that's
that's the first one and we we're going
to say that even though it may seem that
the greedy algorithm is good because you
get an order you service it so it seems
like you're going to really get
you're in your taxi faster it's not
necessarily the case okay because well
this because of this narrow vision that
I told you before maybe if you wait 30
seconds you'll have a taxi which is
closer to you and that can lead to to
lower distances so the next step that
that I follow here is on the graph there
you can see the amount of orders that we
have there every minute so from 7 to 701
we have 25 services then we have 14 and
so forth so the idea here is what
happens if instead of service in every
time I get an order I service it I wait
one minute okay so this means that at
most you'll be waiting one minute to get
what's what your taxi or your or your
car is going to be which is not much
time but actually this gives us more
vision of our problem because for
example in the first minute we go from
servicing one by one to servicing five
at 25 at a time so you have a broader
vision and you can make better decisions
here and and that's basically what we
are doing here so we are going to
increase the information we have and we
are going to postpone the assignments
and we are going to run this new
algorithm every minute okay and by so
basically here what I say is so we have
right now at every minute we have M
trips and so our number of trips and a
number of drivers and I have to make the
best assignment here which is to
minimize the distance from the current
position to to the to the pickup point
and in this case this is an assignment
problem okay in optimization it's a very
widely studied problem and there are
specific algorithms for this like the
Hungarian algorithm the only problem is
the Hungarian algorithm is a very
efficient algorithm but if you want to
evolve it if you want to add more
complex stuff to your to your model it
doesn't work so you need to change it
and so I'm going to use linear
programming for four days which you'll
see that it's it's a more general
technique that allows you to add more
complex stuff okay so before we solve it
and we see the solution what's linear
programming so linear programming which
is also called linear optimization so
it's a mathematical method to to
to achieve the best possible result okay
in a mathematical model that is
expressed with linear expressions okay
in this case in equations and this is
the the form that that a linear program
has okay so I have my well this is the
the the how it looks like and and the
components of a decision oh sorry of a
linear program are the following the
first one is the decision variable so
normally in optimization so optimization
is used to make decisions so we have
decision variables which is what is it
that I'm expecting my model to tell me
what to do and in this case is I have
drivers
I have trips so the decision I have to
make is which driver goes with which
trip so my decision variable here our
binary variables connecting every every
driver with every trip okay then I have
an objective function an objective
function is a metric that allows me to
compare different solutions and and
decide which one is is best in this case
we're minimizing total distance so my
objective function if I have two
different assignments and I compare what
are the distances that I covered with
both of them the one with the lowest one
is best so that's that's the idea of the
objective function and finally the
constraints which the constraints
basically tell you what what solutions
are actually doable or feasible that we
call in in mathematics and basically
this so there are many types of
constraints but we could think that
there are two main type of constraints
we have physical constraints in this
case it's hard to see but for example in
a traditional logistics program a
physical constraint is you cannot load
more stuff in a truck that is actual
capacity that's a physical constraint
and you can have also business
constraints like for example I don't
want to service I don't want to assign
drivers to trips that take more than 20
kilometers for example that's a business
constraint that's that's a constraint
that your company takes and in in in any
solution that don't doesn't satisfy that
constraint is not is not a it's not good
enough for us okay
and well linear programming I forgot to
say this before but linear programming
is is not a new it's not a new technique
actually it was well it is started in
the 19th century but it was mainly
developed before the Second World War
and during the Second World War it was
used for positioning troops and very
interestingly with the previous talk
that we have here it was the first
problem that it was solved here was the
diet problem which is so in the UK they
had this this problem this economic
problem and they they they needed to
feed their troops with the with with the
with the with good quality products but
to minimize the price of those and and
basically starting analyzing this
problem is how they came with many of
the techniques that were developed here
and also during World War the Second
World War it was when it was most
developed and and why is it so powerful
even though it's an old technique well
because well we could in the
optimization we can make a difference
between excite and approximate
algorithms and this is an excitatory
theme is the one that ensures that it
that it has found an optimal solution
and this is an exact algorithm the only
problem is if your problem is too large
maybe it takes an infinite amount of
time so you have to be careful about
this then also linear programming is a
common mathematical language in
optimization so even though at the end
you end up using another technique in
papers you'll find that many
mathematicians use this language so that
it's like the common language to
communicate an optimization model and
then in the figure below what I wanted
to show is that in optimization there is
a lot of different techniques and linear
programming and the related techniques
are just a small amount a subset of
those techniques but the amount of
problems of optimization problems that
can be solved with linear programming is
in comparison to all the problems is
very is very large so it's actually very
very interesting technique okay so so
now we know what a linear programming
and let's let's model our problem
encoded using well I'm going to use our
tools our tools is so is an optimization
solver developed by Google actually it's
not a solver
it's a rapper of different solvers ok so
they they have made this API to connect
to different solvers and both commercial
and open source so it's free sorry so
it's it's a very interesting software
for python there is also bulb the bulb
solver which is also very interesting
but this one is more efficient because
of how it connects with with the the the
source solvers ok so well we are going
to be using the PI R app LP which is the
solar for linear programming and this is
how how you initiate it in particular
we're going to connect to the source
solver the CBS CB c solver which is a
free solver it's among the free solvers
is one of the most powerful it depends
on the problem but it's one of the main
one of the most powerful so again let's
try to identify all the other different
parts of our problems so we have the
different indices or sets of our
problems so we have the orders and what
it should say drivers and then as input
data we have the distance from from the
current positions of my drivers to the
pickup points of the different orders ok
so and then what I need my in my problem
I need my variables I have a set of
binary variables that again as I told
you before they are connecting my
drivers to my to my services here so
they are binary variables that are going
to tell me whether they are or not a
matched and that's how you define them
with with this by rap LP as a library
and then my objective function which is
I want to minimize the total distance
the total empty distance which is that
function okay and that's how you code it
with by rap LP it looks ugly actually
when you code it and this is well
because this is a general library I
actually if you especially with
commercial solvers they have a very
beautiful way of
and it's it's much easier but again this
is it's better so it's interesting to
use this rapper because then you can
connect to different solvers and compare
the performance then in terms of
constraints so we have the first
constraint that we have here is that
every driver is assigned to at most one
trip
these may this may seem obvious but you
have to tell the model how your system
may work because otherwise the model
doesn't know how it has to work so and
that's how you read it so you say so
every driver so for every driver the
some of the services that I assign him
it's smaller or equal to one and then
again every trip is assigned to at most
one driver so again so for every trip
the sum of drivers assigned to that trip
is is smaller or equal to one okay and
that's how you translate it with this
library and finally we want to assign as
many trips as possible one of the
assumptions I made at the beginning is
that we are always going to have idle
drivers but in case we didn't the
maximum number of trips that I can
assign is the minimum between the number
of idle drivers and and the number of
services that I have so there what I'm
saying is I need to make all these
assignments okay and that's that's how
you how you do it okay so so now we know
what's linear optimization we have coded
R so we have written our our model in
mathematical for a notation we have
coded it and now we want to solve it
okay and we'll just solve it with this
library is very easy you just call
solver solve and you have a solution you
check if it's optimal or not and that's
that's it and but now let's see what
happens behind so the scene so what's
really happening and how you solve this
problem okay so in this case if with
since we're working with linear
optimization what we have it's like
every constraint is is in a hyperplane
of the of the space where you're working
so basically we have a lot of
hyperplanes that are
intersecting what with another okay and
you end up with a figure like the one
you have on on your right which it
should be in three dimensions but it
could be in any dimension there and what
you can you end up with a polytope okay
the interesting thing about this is that
there is theorems or a mathematical
result that states that the ultimate
solution is at one of the extreme points
of that poly tope which is basically at
one of the intersection of these many
hyper planes okay and that's good
because that reduces your your search
when looking for for the optimal
solution okay and there is also one
interesting characteristic that is that
it's at these extreme points I know that
if I have M M constraints and n
variables I know that I haven't going to
have M variables with value different
well greater or equal to zero and I'm
going to have n minus n so n minus M
sorry so the number of variables minus
the number of constraints variables that
are going to be exactly zero and this
property is used to solve this algorithm
and the way you solve it is basically so
you start from one extreme point and you
start exploring different extreme points
until you find one in which you see that
there is no potential of improvement
okay and when you reach that point it's
it's when when you were done okay now
this is how you solve the problem for
when you have when all your variables
are are continuous the problem is our
variables are no continues are binaries
or they're integer I'm not going to dive
deep into this but basically if you have
integer variables that means well you
need another technique which is based on
the simplex algorithm but basically you
need to build this type of trees with
branch and bound or other more evolved
techniques that rely on this branch and
bound algorithm but basically it gets
more complex as you can see because if
your variables are continuous you stop
your start and stop in the subproblem
one if you have integer variables this
is what you get okay and this is just a
quick note about about what makes a good
solver there's a huge difference between
commercial and free solvers when it
comes to linear programming and these
are the three things that I advise you
to take a look at if you want to see if
yours is good or not okay which is the
resolve which is how your solver tries
to reduce the this poly tope in order to
make it faster to reduce and I can tell
you with a commercial solver you can
have the problem solved in a matter of
seconds and with a free one you can you
can take minutes okay then the
heuristics that it used in order to find
these integer solutions and then the
parallel communication between the
different trees that we saw in the in
the previous one okay
again very fast here there's a good
thing about this assignment problem
which is that our matrix here is totally
unimodular which basically means that
every sub matrix every square sub matrix
has determinant 1 0 or minus 1 and this
basically gives us a very cool property
and for our our problem we can define
all our variables are continuous and yet
our solution will be integer so this is
a very interesting result because it
makes it easier to solve and actually a
very efficient algorithm for for the
problem we're solving here so now we
know how this works we solve it and and
this is the different results we get
with a greedy algorithm and with the
assignment one ok we see a 13% of
improvement and for example in the
northeast part of the map you can see
that with the greedy algorithm we had a
very inefficient assignment now we have
been able to improve it so that's that's
a good thing it's it's very important to
visualize it because it allows you to
really see what's what's happening if
your algorithm is working or not and and
yet step 3 which is so step 3 is still
working progress
ok but I'm going to introduce you to the
idea that we have here which is how we
can still improve this algorithm so
right now we have been focusing on
assigning the driver that is closer to
it but actually we want we need more
information
about what's happening in order to
improve this algorithm and this is the
supply-demand matching so I want to
forecast what's the demand going to be
like in the next 30 minutes or 60
minutes so that I can make better
decisions on how to move my my or how to
assign these this drivers okay so before
that you need to build a reference grid
so that you can calculate the you can
forecast the demand in every of those
grids and then use historical data of
the day of the historical orders that
you got plus and reach your data this is
one very interesting point that we
always do a carto and this is something
that I never I not always did in my
previous companies but it's very
interesting which is enriching your data
which is in this problem is very very
important and why is it important
because if you only take into account
your historical data of the orders you
got you will be probably biased because
you depend on where your drivers have
been you don't know where your
competitors have their cars so you can
be biased by where your actual demand is
but you don't know if there's more
demand yet that you can that you can
have okay and in this case one of a very
interesting source of data that we could
use to enrich our data is footfall data
and and the OD matrix data that I will
show you here so here what we can see is
the amount of people so actually this
picture is better so here what we can
see for example is in a in a 250 by 250
meters so 250 sorry by 250 meters great
and we have the estimated sorry not
estimated the actual data on the
aggregated number sorry of visitors that
we had at every of these sales on a
Monday morning on a Thursday evening on
a Sunday night so here you can see that
there are different patterns of where
people are and actually we can also have
these OD matrix information that will
it's very small but there's a cell
painted in in light blue and here what
we can see is so people that are that
visit that cell where they come from so
this is very powerful
because for example on a Thursday
evening if you know where people at a
specific place for example you look for
a working place and you see okay where
people come from you can see where those
people come from and and you can take
that to reach your data and actually
make better decisions on where you
should place your cars or your drivers
to get more more services let's say so
the idea here is that we wouldn't we
would end up with with with a
forecasting result okay again this is
work in progress so this is a simulation
that we ran in order to to test if this
idea was good so we would end up with
this with this forecasting result where
we can see the amount of orders that we
could expect in the following 60 minutes
and then we have where our cars are
position so in red I would have those
that I want to get to the city centre
because I'm going to have a lot of
demand there and in purple I have the
cars that I don't I I want to keep if I
can I want to keep them there because
that's where my demand is going to be in
the next hour so if I take them far from
the city center it's going to I'm going
to increase the number of empty
kilometers they drive okay so and just
to show you for example with the
Hungarian algorithm that I told you
before was like the first approach that
you can follow to solve this assignment
problem this can no cannot be done so
the good thing about linear programming
it is that it allows you to make this
type of constraint so here we have a
logical constraints that you can
linearize and what this is how you
transform it so again next steps we
could this was we made a lot of
assumptions here so you can no doubt
these assumptions may make sense for
your business or your problem so again
this programming can can get a lot
harder and the good thing about linear
programming is that you could add all
these components to your to your problem
yesin takeaways well the the the the
powerful the power of linear programming
then visualization is very important
when solving this type of problems to
get an idea of what's happening around
in your city where people move
where you get the orders and so forth
and then data enrichment to to avoid
these bias that you can have if you only
use your own data so well thank you very
much for listening for these great so I
have a few questions
what is your customer no no there's no
no customer here okay the second
question is that did you consider time
because that I have watched a movie
called the butterfly effect if you
change something something else will
change so for example if you suggest
people to a different route it could be
the new route will become very crowded
then what do you have a real time
adjustment for example if I go to my
office in the morning right you know
first of all it tells me you know if I
started leave at 8:15 mmm
it tells me it tells me 25 minutes in
the beginning but gradually it will
increase 15 minutes but if I started
leave at 9 o'clock it won't tell me 45
minutes but gradually it will become 25
minutes yeah yeah so this time is also
very important dimension to you also
just this at real time so did you have
actually a test of the whole process I
mean what you said is just one
prediction did you also have a final
day-to-day final adjustment to look at
it overall and also like when there is
only one people use your software and
also the everybody use your software and
also if there is an AI system everybody
take this this will all be different
things you know this time okay well if I
don't remember all your questions I'll
ask you later so the first thing about
time as I said before yes so we could we
could have thought about time the only
thing is I we chose here distance no
because this is the final product but
because it's easier to visualize so it's
easier to visualize in a map that you're
actually taking a shorter route so that
actually you're taking a shorter
distance but of course in this is this
problem it makes more sense to take the
ETA as also the expected time of arrival
from from where your driver is to the
pickup point that's what actually makes
sense for this and that is what you
should be taken into account and of
course in real time so that you can
calculate that in real time and you know
what's the expected time of arrival
of all the drivers and you actually make
the the
decision based on real-time information
but again here it was just to show you
this and and I thought it was easier
because when I draw the results when I
plotted the results with with distance
and with time with time it's not always
obvious that you are actually making the
shortest path so that's why I chose here
distance but yes it makes sense and can
you repeat that the next question sorry
yeah so so basically the other things
that did you have a final evaluation so
for example for a whole day if people
actually use your software well that
actually improve things so because if
everybody's changing real-time it could
eventually waste more time you never
know so if everyone sorry if everyone if
everybody is using this so supposing
right if you're at you're going to stock
market you say okay this is this stock
making money and I change every second
so this now those also another stock if
you change different different stock
what cost some Commission fee so you
know if you change too fast then it will
not help you to save time so what is
time sped them and also did you have an
evaluation eventually if there's there's
a whole region use your software whether
really save time yeah well at this at
this moment is not being used so the
idea here is how you test this this type
of problems so they're different from
traditional ones here you need you need
to simulate what's happening in cities
so we could use for example discrete
event simulation to to simulate what's
happened throughout the day and you can
actually measure this this sort of thing
so what happens if but yeah so we would
use discrete event simulation through a
whole day and simulate what happens and
we've we've tested like that but I don't
see the problem with what you say about
if everyone is using this so I don't I
don't I don't see I mean if if you have
a city and people are using this this
type of service
suppose that we increase the demand for
example but I mean this is actually what
happens today with with this racer
companies the only thing is they are now
located I mean they are they try to
locate them intelligently but we're here
trying to go a step further in how to to
locate those those drivers but
the problem is the same as we have today
so you can have if there's a peak of
demand in a certain place of the city
you you may end up with not having
enough you know drivers there so that
can happen so thank you very much for
the talk
my question is about the preparation of
data for the linear programming
algorithm you're using so you mentioned
that you have this assumption that you
don't you always have either drivers yes
but if you could actually consider to be
idle drivers and then you can you could
add the delay for the possible drivers
to the end result sorry so how do you as
a suggestion maybe you could also add to
be either drivers to the list of drivers
as a possible candidate yeah yeah
actually what we did so actually here
when we simulated this data we it's not
that we if we have in total 100 orders
in these 5 minutes we have 100 drivers
it's not like that we actually have less
I don't know if it's I don't know the
number but we have less and what we
consider is okay if this driver is
assigned to this to this specific travel
I know when he when they are going to
finish so I know when he's going to be
idle again so that I can I can I can
assign them to a different one that was
your suggestion right yeah thank you
[Music]